Hey, everyone,
let's start with a simple question.
Why do things get cheaper the more you do them?
Why does your first try at building something feel slow ...
and expensive, but by the fifth or tenth time,
it's easier, faster,
and cheaper to do?
That's not just your brain getting better.
It's a real business principle called the learning curve.
And the learning rate is what helps us measure that improvement.
It's going to show us how much more efficient you ...
become as total output increases.
So today, what we're going to look at is ...
what the learning curve is, how it's different from ...
economies of scale, and how to calculate a ...
learning rate using some real numbers.
Let's jump into it.
The learning curve shows how average cost per unit ...
decreases as cumulative total output or cumulative output rises.
This happens because people get faster,
they make less mistakes, tools get better,
and the processes improve.
In the production process, we usually express this as a learning rate.
For example, an 80%
learning rate means that every time total production ...
doubles, the average cost per unit ...
drops to 80% of what it was before.
Let's look at how this looks graphically.
Here we have a cumulative total output,
or excuse me, an average cost curve here.
Cost per unit on our vertical axis,
cumulative output on the horizontal axis.
Now, let's have the learning effect ...
take place in our learning curve,
and we're going to shift down this average cost curve.
And the reason this takes place is because of the ...
learning rate, the learning effect as well.
So notice on the top average cost curve,
I was producing one unit of output,
and it cost me $10,000 per unit to do so.
But because of the learning effect,
learning rates, what happens?
We shift that, that average cost curve down.
And now if we were to go back,
we can make that first unit at $8,000.
But in reality, as we're doubling our ...
production here, we're going to be producing ...
that second unit for a little bit cheaper than what we're ...
actually producing or what we would have produced before.
So you'll notice that at the second unit,
if we were on the original average cost curve,
it it would have cost us slightly less than 10,000.
But because of learning effect,
we've learned how to do stuff better.
We have an improvement in technology and improvement ...
in tools, all those things.
What takes place is we can actually now produce that ...
second unit of output.
We have doubled our output in this case,
but we can produce that second unit of output at a ...
lower average cost per unit.
Now, let's make sure that we are ...
not confusing the learning effect,
which would be the Distance here,
the learning rate with economies of scale.
Economies of scale are going to be spreading the fixed cost ...
over a large amount of output.
And so as we move down one average cost curve,
we're going to have economies of scale, all right?
That's a lowering of your average total cost over output.
The learning effects that comes from getting better at ...
work, having improvements in ...
technology, making fewer mistakes,
having faster labor, all those things that go into ...
shifting down this average cost curve to a lower cost per unit basis.
Now, let's look at how this works in an example.
So, we have a company building ...
a new electric scooter.
The first unit costs 10,000 build.
After building two scooters, the average cost per scooter ...
has dropped to $8,000.
So similar to what we were looking at in a previous ...
graph, now,
scooter one was $10,000 to build,
but scooter two is $6,000 to build.
Total cost $16,000 to build those two scooters.
The average cost to build scooter one was $10,001 ...
divided by the lone scooter, or 10,000.
And the average cost to build the two scooters is 16,000 ...
divided by two, which is going to give us the ...
8,000 that we saw earlier.
Now, let's calculate the learning rate.
So we're going to bring in this formula here.
The learning rate is equal to the average cost of the ...
second scooter or the fourth scooter or the eighth scooter ...
or whatever it happens to be, divided by the average cost of ...
the first scooter.
We're going to multiply that by 100%,
and that's going to give us our learning rate.
So, so here we have $8,000,
the average cost of building the two scooters divided by 10,000.
And we're going to multiply that by 100%,
and that gives us 80%.
So what that means is every time output doubles,
average cost drops to 80% of the previous level.
If we were to lock in on that 80%
and we get no more learning effects,
then, then what we could see is ...
output continues to double as we go from two scooters to four scooters.
So the average cost of doing four scooters,
we would do 80% times the 8,000 what we ...
previously done, and that gives us $6,400.
Now go from four scooters to eight scooters,
and we're maintaining that 80%
learning rate, and that gives us a total of ...
5,120 as the average cost of making those eight scooters.
We're going to continue to do this with 16 scooters.
80% our learning rate times the ...
previous $5,120 and now that gives us $4,096.
So what we can see here is that the learning effect is ...
going to allow us to continue to lower the average cost of ...
producing those scooters.
And again, this is different from ...
economies of scale, which maintains us on one ...
average cost curve, whereas the learning rate ...
allows us to shift different down our average cost curve.
So strategically, why this matters?
Well, it helps businesses do a lot of things.
It helps them forecast how fast their costs will fall,
it helps them decide when to scale up and it also helps ...
them price products more competitively over time.
So these big companies like Tesla,
Boeing and Apple, who are huge in production ...
costs, they can use these learning ...
curves to plan staffing, pricing and production goals.
And startups in particular can use them,
the learning rates, that is to help survive early. High cost.
All right, that's all that I have.
I hope you've enjoyed it.